we make way for the popular chris sims
co-host pro football talk live former
nfl quarterback
he's got his quarterback list counting
down to number three and we've got
controversy at number three
chris how dare you you picked
aaron rodgers as the third best
quarterback in the nfl
i know it hurt my heart as you know i
mean i
am the uh the leader of the the
bandwagon fans for aaron rodgers
uh and you know i i unleashed my one and
two
two today on pro football talk just so
you know that patrick mahomes won
russell wilson two
aaron rodgers three but mike i mean uh
dan just on that
yeah sorry i'm getting confused
but just on that with aaron rodgers
still
awesome we know that that this is the
first time
that i would say since about midway
through 2010
at least in my book where i go oh he's
not the best quarterback in the nfl
anymore
still really special we know he's got a
great arm
good decision maker but i think with
where we're at in his career
and then russell wilson and patrick
mahomes uh
yes i think they've surpassed aaron
rodgers here in the past year for me at
least
well i thought the controversy is that
you had rogers up that high
it feels like hey slipping here
you know a lot of people are bailing on
aaron rodgers here
well you know for whatever reason people
like to bail on aaron rodgers i don't
know what it is you know
they expect him to just make the super
bowl every year and carry the team
and you know to me hey the support
system has not been there for aaron
rodgers
for for me there is no doubt he's a top
five quarterback in football
uh i i i have a hard time like really
taking anybody seriously that would
think like okay maybe if you wanted to
put him at six
all right but if you're trying to tell
me he's 10 or 11 or something like that
i would just go
i'm sorry uh you need to come watch film
with me and
you need to reevaluate things but no i
mean we're still talking
maybe other than patrick mahomes the
greatest arm in the sport
okay still unbelievably quick release
you know
understands how to take care of the
football that was a 10-6 football team
last year
that they were at 13-3 because of aaron
rodgers you know
i don't think i talked to you during the
season i don't think either one of us
were blown away by
green bay the team during the regular
season we just knew they were a good
team
with a really special quarterback and we
thought ooh maybe that could be
something so
yeah don't sleep on aaron rodgers all
right but give me the criteria of how
you were ranking these quarterbacks
sure i went from i'm like a coach on the
hot seat right
and here's my pecking order for my top
40 quarterbacks
who i trust and think the best is
on right on down the list here so yeah
it's not easy to do but that was my
criteria it's about 2020
has nothing to do about 2010 2015
career accomplishments it's a what have
you done for me lately league and i'm
evaluating
what i think the quarterbacks are going
to be for this 2020 season
all right i got the danettes who were
yelling at each other what's
what's the problem here you guys we all
have issues with chris's list in
different areas okay
pick a guy who wants mclovin go first so
when drew brees throws 40 touchdowns and
five picks next year
he's still the 16th best quarterback in
the nfl if you're doing 20 20. well okay
hey all right all right mclovin okay
first off
don't get into me with all the stats
crap all the time whoever plays
quarterback
for the saints is going to have great
stats they went 5-0 with teddy
bridgewater
last year okay all right so and then the
other thing i would tell
you too is you know again drew brees
really good great yeah okay let's go
through it oh okay one of the best
receivers in football one of the better
tight ends of football
maybe the best offensive mind in this
board oh definitely one of the five best
offensive lines in the sport
and mclovin if he was still a top five
or top ten quarterback
they wouldn't be pushing him out the
door after this year they'd be going
let's get a deal done and stay here
longer so
not that they're pushing him out the
door but the writing's on the wall you
know what i'm trying to say
they're going to the taysom hill era so
drew brees still really awesome
certainly capable of winning a super
bowl
um but no i don't think he's the type of
talent like we've seen in the playoffs
the last few years that when
the offense isn't executing he can't
make a lot happen by himself
and that is big to me in evaluation yes
yes yeah he could never throw for 71
yards in a game like ryan tannehill in
the playoffs
he'd never be able to accomplish that
feat he couldn't accomplish
the two touchdown passes he threw in the
game to put them up 14 to three
so how about that you don't think he's
gonna do that like no no i don't think
drew brees he can't throw the ball
last 40 yards guys so the first
touchdown pass he can't even attempt to
throw
the second throw was a power throw in
the back left corner with people around
him so
yes drew brees is really good but all
i'm just saying mclevin
don't you're you're taking the saints
offense and sean payton
i'm just talking about quarterbacks yeah
we'll see how great those wide receivers
in line are when taysom hills the
quarterback that great offensive line
okay all right who's next up paulie all
right chris uh russell wilson number two
no no all right let's go to um who gives
you a better chance to win next year
number nine on your list matt stafford
or number 15 on your list tom brady
well i mean okay so all right so this is
where this is against dicey
listen i understand you're we're used to
tom brady tom brady
tom brady he's awesome i mean yeah i
mean i'm not going to argue with you if
you think he's the greatest quarterback
of all time
you put tom brady in detroit okay it
ain't gonna look like tom brady i'm just
telling you he can't do some of the
things that matthew stafford can do
you put matthew stafford in new england
last year they're a better football team
i'm sorry drew tom brady still really
good
obviously can win the super bowl no
doubt about it
you know but they didn't win one game
because of tom brady last year
not one they played through their
defense and then he just didn't screw
games up so yes i think right now
there's no doubt in my mind that matthew
stafford is a better player can do more
with less
and can do more with more i don't like
you guys too
i'm not coming okay guys okay
who who's next here what do you have
that's so funny uh you know i thought
that at four and five was interesting
with desean watson and lamar jackson
what
uh pushed watson over the edge a little
higher than
than lamar jackson i i think the big
thing is
the polish passer department that to me
is
still where lamar jackson has certainly
room to grow we saw him get a lot better
from year one to year two but
i think you know in a broad statement
lamar jackson needs a certain type of
offense of system around him right now
desean watson i think can play in any
system
and is a more polished passer than a
lamar jackson at this point in this
career
you know to where we've seen again you
know the last two years in the playoffs
when the ravens couldn't physically
dominate a team up front and on the line
of scrimmage they had to rely on the
pass game
and they're just lamar's not there yet
to be like oh okay hey guys the game's
not
the run game's not working jump on my
back i'll throw it 40 times and we'll
win the game
i don't think he's at that level yet as
special as he is but he certainly got
better and he could be a guy that could
be number one two three or four next
year
yes todd i wouldn't kill you over it but
why six and seven why
wentz over matt ryan and not ryan ahead
of went and how does someone that
doesn't even have a team yet
make the top 10 in cam newton well yeah
that was probably the hard first off
with cam newton this is one of the
hardest ones now listen
he kind of got screwed over by his old
team as far as when they let him go and
all the chairs were filled
for starting quarterback so that's where
he's been screwed over
and cam newton's the kind of guy that
nobody's gonna bring in as a backup
quarterback
because he's gonna make your starter
look not very good
unless you're named like watson mahomes
aaron rodgers or those guys i mean
if you bring him into certain teams you
know
the player's gonna go in the locker room
after the day's over practice sometimes
did you see our backup did you see cam
newton he was throwing lasers everywhere
and it's gonna cause a division within
the team so he's
stuck in a tough spot not because of
where he's at
uh but because of the way carolina
handled the situation
now to six and seven hey i'm a big matt
ryan fan i don't think he gets enough
credit
as you can tell though i'm a big carson
wentz fan really carson wentz
one of the only things i look at as a
weakness to him is maybe protecting his
body a little bit
and of course you know hey yeah it
sounds like he could be a better leader
and and teammate in the locker room but
man fritzi who who was his running back
at the end of the year last year
who was this top receiver come on fritzi
who's our who are they who are they
frenzy
he only knows the bronco roster that's
right exactly so i'm just saying most
people can't even name the people that
were on the offensive carson wentz last
year and yet they went to the playoffs
because he was maybe arguably one of the
greatest one-man
band one-man shows in football last year
so that's why i give them the advantage
there yes todd
was wilbert montgomery and harold
carmichael was there like a keith
crepley
title he's chris sims co-host of pro
football talk
where would colin kaepernick be on this
list oh that's a good question now
i'll say this when he was getting
blackballed by the nfl
and all that you know he certainly was
right around the top half of football
as a starting quarterback in the nfl in
my opinion
you know right like the talent of colin
kaepernick
is superstar top five top 10 talent
right now i couldn't find it in my heart
to put him in the top
40. just from the standpoint of he
hasn't played football in three years
and as you guys know and as bad at
athletes as all the danettes are not
dead you're a great athlete absolutely
but as you know
when you take a long time off from any
sport it's not easy to come back and be
good at it even if you're playing pickup
basketball
let alone quarterback where you can't
practice it you can't
emulate any of the things that go on so
would you put him
over case keenum if i said you're on the
hot seat
you're on the hot dog okay nope not the
second
uh mitchell trubisky um
no no do i think he has a higher end and
like a higher ceiling
certainly but i can't say that i can
feel that with confidence with a guy
that
hasn't had offense defense alignment and
how to make decisions and play the game
in so long
so like he should be on a team dan i'll
say that for sure
and with the new practice rules uh
practice uh
practice team rules and all those things
you know
i think a team is stupid to not bring
him on there and just go hey let's let
him have a year here develop see what
he's got he's got big time talent maybe
he's our awesome backup next year
that's what you should do with colin
kaepernick the hall of fame
game cancelled we keep saying we have
been saying the nfl has time
they can look at all these other leagues
the nfl doesn't have time chris
uh what kind of pre-season adjustments
do you think we're looking at here
i mean i i don't know what to expect you
know because yeah we're in a tough spot
you know you you look at where we are as
a country right now
and where coven 19 is going and you know
it's scary in some states still
so you know i was more optimistic about
us playing games and having a full
season i feel like a month ago that i
feel right now i don't know how you feel
about it but
you know i i i don't know what to say do
you think it starts on time
right now in my heart of hearts no
because i think that we're going to get
into like the second week of training
camp
and you're going to have a few teams
that have like multiple players on their
team just like we're seeing in college
that
kobit 19 is starting to spread through
the team and then what are they going to
do
so that's to me where it's concerning i
don't see
how you can possibly say or think you
don't think there'll be an
outbreak of some sort on these teams
throughout august
so yeah right now i don't i don't i
don't feel good about that if you're the
commissioner do you punish the
buccaneers and seahawks because they've
been holding workouts
no i don't i don't first off i don't
think many nfl players really care about
kobe 19. i think they respect it
like and they don't want any of their
family members or people to get sick
like that
but i can just tell you if you take me
back into 28 year old chris sims when i
was playing football
i'd be like screw covered 19. i'm okay
i want to play football this year and i
think most players
are like that let alone like listen tom
brady russell wilson they care about
people i know
that these are good people but they're
also going hey
as far as i know right now i'm gonna be
expected to perform and be the man here
in a few weeks so
i need to practice and i need to get
better and they're kind of you know
weighing that out i get why brady's
doing it because brady
you know i i don't know how much
pressure that the outside is putting on
him but he's putting it on himself
he's got to come in and hit the ground
running with this team
it's not like he's still in new england
he's got a whole new team
offense head coach offensive coordinator
all of that
i get why he's doing it i just didn't
know if the nfl is going to look at this
and say
you know i can't have you guys you know
getting together like this
well yeah i mean you know it's nice of
them to say but
you know again it's where we are in this
country right now how can you tell
certain people that when the rules in
some states don't apply the same or
whatever it may be
you know if i'm in a quarterback who's
like sitting there trying to listen to
the nfl
and the nflpa and listen to the rules of
my state
and then i see a guy like tom brady or
russell wilson throwing footballs and
getting better
i'm sitting at home going okay screw it
i need to get out there and start
getting better
hey you know wide receivers running
backs let's go we got to practice and
you know most quarterbacks are such type
a ocd
personalities they're stressing about
training camp right now
i need to throw more i need to get
better at this i need to do that and
it's hard to just sit home and think
like oh i'm going to have a pass in my
backyard and i'm going to get better
it's good to talk to you chris are you
happy you did your quarterback rankings
i mean i i'm i i love doing it uh
i'm happy it's over okay i'm sick of
defending myself at one point
i was gonna go through this idea of
executioners here i don't like you guys
wow what a tough guy
i don't like you guys
thank you chris good to talk to you good
talking to you too be good see you guys
peace out chris chris sims co-host of
pro football don't play any of you guys
he's soft he's soft that's funny